si on se faisait un petit ce qu'il
fallait pas louper média pas mal on va
commencer avec cette info qui vous a
j'en suis sûr vous a pas échappé c'est
ce qui a été dit sur monsieur Reichmann
figurez-vous qu'il a découvert qu'il
était mort
regardez nous sommes le 8 mai il est
22h51 le 8 mai et là qu'est-ce que
j'apprends Jean-Luc Reichmann est mort
oui ah oui regardez bien Jean-Luc
Reichmann est mort il est décédé le 9
mai 2023 à l'âge de 62 ans c'est-à-dire
demain la disparition inattendue tu
m'étonnes du présentateur des douze
coups de midi a déclenché une importante
vague d'émotion en France je suis mort
demain ne vous inquiétez pas tout va
bien je voulais quand même vous
souhaiter une bonne nuit et une bonne
fin de vie
alors ceci dit
c'est quand même à devenir un classique
sur les réseaux alors vous Daniel Moreau
enfin tous les deux le 2 novembre ce qui
est quand même
un matin je
reçois de SMS de gens que je m'envoyait
pas des SMS tout le temps ça va tu vas
bien de nous des nouvelles et ça je
trouvais ça bizarre en fait sur ma fiche
Wikipédia il y avait marqué né le 2
novembre 1963 morte le et le jour où
voilà le jour où ça s'est passé
hyper flippant quoi un petit intérêt de
buzz de faire tourner chez toi encore je
les ai pas TPMP tous les jours j'étais
enfin je faisais France 2 un petit peu
mais j'étais pas hyper connue donc je me
suis
plus exposez
les flippant c'est de se dire que
quelqu'un
a pris cinq minutes
ça c'est flippant parce que je ne sais
pas de de rumeurs
je me promenais avec mon fils c'était
dans le Sud-Ouest on s'en fout
d'ailleurs du reste et j'ai eu un truc
dans un tableau ID de je sais plus
c'était public ou voici où on avait
titré elle aime les petits jeunes
23 ans d'écart avec moi mais quand même
enfin voilà mais ça c'est plus voilà
c'est plus un détournement c'est pas une
fake news
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
qui est quand même un site très sérieux
etc s'il y a quand même des failles non
mais vous avez beaucoup de monde
mais c'est pas normal
peut écrire oh c'est en quelle année ça
c'est quoi
une mort médiatique peut-être et puis
magazine international je dois dire
à l'étranger
c'est vous sur la photo
[Rires]
c'est très vite c'est facile à
déventures pas non plus cheval